Good evening.
We'll try that one more time. It's cold.
It's raining. I don't I don't fault you for not saying it
the way you should have. All right. Here we
go. Good evening.
Thank you. Well, I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time up here because we have to get from Moses until the apocalypse
tonight. And so I'm
excited about it. But you're a
guest tonight. We want to say welcome. We don't believe it's an accident
that you're here. If you came in the rain, you're our kind of people and I
was going to introduce Dr. Emerson as
the weatherman tonight because every time he comes there's snow or ice or
rain or fog or whatever, but I'm
glad that he's here. I'm sad that we only get him three nights, but
let's pray together and then I'll welcome Dr. Men father.
Thank you so much for your word and how it
challenges Us and how it teaches us Lord instruct us
tonight father to know how to read it for all
it's worth Lord it is
It is.
Sweeter than honeycomb.
And and it is great reward. And so I
pray father tonight. We would we would taste it sweetness, but we
would also see its reward. Thank you for Dr. Emerson for his
willingness to come and Lord. I pray that that tonight
you will guide him in his steps in his words and
it's in Jesus and we pray amen.
Well, thanks Phil. Thanks for having me and inviting me.
It's been a blessing to be with you the last month or
so. I do I do regret that
we couldn't meet the second week.
I guess I'm either the weatherman or the post
office because I'm here.
Rain or shine ice or snow whatever, but it
has been fun.
I I'm gonna have to use a cheat sheet tonight.
Because we have so much to cover. The good news is the cheat
sheet is in the Bible.
So if you want to turn your Bible.
To Psalm 78 Psalm 78
is going to help us summarize.
Pretty much the entire rest of Israel's history.
And I'll still walk you through the the
books in terms of mentioning them and mentioning the
story and following what we've talked about so far, but Psalm
78 will help us as we begin and the
Lord.
Helped me yesterday. This was actually the reading yesterday from the
Psalms and I thought hey, this will be helpful tomorrow
night. So that was in the Lord's good Providence
to have that ready so Psalm 78.
a mask goal of asaph
give ear o my people to my teaching incline your
ears to the words of my mouth.
I will open my mouth in a parable. I will
utter dark sayings from of old things that
we have heard and known that our fathers have told us.
We will not hide them from their children, but tell to their
coming Generation The Glorious Deeds of the Lord and his might
and the Wonders that he has done.
He established a testimony in Jacob and appointed a
law in Israel when he commanded our fathers to
teach their children that the Next Generation might know them the children
yet unborn and arise and tell them to their children so
they should set their hope in God and not forget the
works of God, but keep his Commandments and that
they should not be like their father is a stubborn and rebellious generation a
generation whose heart was not steadfast.
Whose Spirit was not faithful to God?
The ephraimites armed with the bow turned back on the day of battle.
They did not keep God's covenant, but refused to walk according to
his law they forgot his works and the Wonders
that he had shown them in the sight of their fathers. He performed
wonders in the land of Egypt in the fields of Zohan.
He divided the sea and let them pass through it and made the water
stand like a heap in the daytime. He led them with a
cloud and all the night with a fiery light. He split rocks
in the wilderness and gave them drink abundantly as from the deep.
He made streams come out of the Rock and caused Waters to
flow down like Rivers.
And here's one of the key verses for at
least for the rest of the Old Testament yet. They send still more
against him.
Rebelling against the most high in the desert. They tested
God in their heart by demanding the food they
craved.
They spoke against God saying can God spread a
table in the wilderness.
He struck the rock. So the water gushed out and streams overflowed.
Can he also give bread or provide meat for
his people?
Therefore when the Lord heard he was full of Wrath a
fire was kindled against Jacob his anger Rose
against Israel because they did not believe in God
and did not trust his saving power.
Now we could keep reading in Psalm 78.
It's pretty much the same thing.
two or three more times
And what happens after where we ended last
week is that God calls Israel out of Egypt?
Remember we're following along in this Grand story
where God has promised through his
promises to Abraham to restore what Adam lost.
That at some point he's going to fulfill his purpose for
creation that his image Bears will fill the Earth will be
fruitful multiply. Obey care and Rule
and how he's going to do that. We've just seen in
Exodus is through the death of the firstborn son the
blood of the Lamb rescuing his people from their enemies.
So God has rescued his people where we ended last week.
And the next thing he does he says, all right. Let's go to my place.
You're my people.
We're going to go to my place.
Brings them out of Egypt.
through the Red Sea
the way that they crossed the Red Sea is how does he do that? He Parts
the waters. He separates the waters and
they walk across on dry land. Does that remind you
of anything that we talked about from week one, right God on
day.
three separated the waters
There was a dry land same things happening with
Israel. It's New Creation language saying they have Noah. All
right, they go across.
Immediately and this is part of what Psalm 78 just described at
the end that we read immediately. First of
all, even before they crossed the Red Sea. What does Israel do they get
to the Red Sea?
And they're like, oh God's got us. We're all good. No.
They start freaking out.
What are we going to do?
Here's this body of water. We can't cross.
Egypt's Army is coming right behind us to destroy us
all and they say let's just go back.
Like maybe Pharaoh will not be mad if we just turn around
and like hey, sorry.
Moses Parts the waters, they go across
now remember when they do that what have they just seen God do
They just saw with their own eyes.
all ten plagues
and God rescuing them from the 10th and
final plague through the blood of the Lamb.
They just saw all that they just saw them. They themselves
took gold and silver and even
Egyptians are following them out of Egypt because they see this
God the god of Israel is the true God and immediately.
when they face
a question, how are we going to cross this water?
They turn to fear and doubt.
Nevertheless God brings them across through the
waters.
on the dry land
the Egyptians are the Egyptian Army's killed
in the water coming after them.
Go through the water kind of like Noah's flood. They go through the water come across immediately.
Once they get across Moses sings. This
great song about God is an awesome God and his great
and he has all these armies and he can destroy anybody. He's just provided
Victory Moses is up here praising and worshiping the Lord.
And the Israelites immediately, what do they say?
God we don't have any water to drink.
It's bitter.
And so God is like hey.
Okay.
You guys remember what just happened but fine. Here's some here's some water you
can drink.
And what it says is in Exodus 16 that
he gave them the water to drink, but he also gave them a
rule and a statute.
when Israel sins
God is gracious to them and present to them but he also gives them a
law.
then
what happens next they complain?
Thanks for the water God, but now we ain't got nothing to eat.
Pharaoh might have been literally killing us with the
work. He was having us do.
But he also fed us.
Now we got no food. What's up with that God. Let's just go back to Egypt.
God says fine.
Here's Manna From Heaven. He gives them what they crave.
Gives them what they ask for but he also then gives them another
Rule and statute. They sin the
complain they doubt they have they lack faith. God is
gracious to them in providing for them. But he
also follows that up with giving them a law.
Eventually, they get to Mount Sinai in Exodus
19.
And at this point God says come up on the mountain with
me.
in Israel's like
yeah.
And God says you know what you're right.
You guys are a bunch of sinful.
doubtful
I want to say jackwagons, but God doesn't
say that he just says look, yeah, don't come up
here. Don't even touch the mountain.
Here's what I'll do instead. I will come down to you.
Instead of you coming up to me, which is what he says to them at first
come up on the mountain.
be
a kingdom of priests
a royal Nation a royal priesthood a holy nation
come up on this mountain with me in my place.
That I have made for you and live with me.
And Israel says Nah, and God's
like yeah, you're right. Don't even touch the mountain.
And he gives them more law at this point and the law that he begins
to give them is first of all the Ten Commandments.
And then he gives them the laws regarding the
priesthood and the Tabernacle.
So, okay Israel. Don't come up here anymore. Don't even
touch the mountain but here's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make there be a way
since you won't come up here and be a kingdom of priests.
I will make you a kingdom with priests and I will come down
to you.
So they were supposed to go up on the mountain and like Adam and Eve dwell
directly with God.
They're sinful though. They say no thanks. God says, yeah, you're
right. Not that he not that. He didn't know that already, but he
confirms what they know about themselves.
And he gives them a kingdom with priests.
now there are priests that mediate that come between
God and Israel
And so he gives them the Priestly laws and
the Tabernacle Tabernacle laws. He gives those to Moses who's up
on the mountain with God. So God says to Moses come up on the mountain. I'll give
you these laws most like all right goes up on the mountain right and
things down.
in the meantime
What's Israel doing?
They're dancing naked.
Around a golden cow.
Which is not the same thing, by the way as the Bison
statue in the middle of OBS campus. Okay, there's not the
same thing. Well, they're dancing naked around this golden calf.
They not only have they rejected God's invitation to
come up on the mountain with him. They are now worshiping a false god.
While he's giving them laws.
About how he can be present to them still.
At this point what we've seen is more sin more law
more sin more law. That's the pattern so
far.
at this point
God understandably says I'm done.
Moses intercedes on their behalf
and he says you know what? I'm a God.
I'm The God Who will show Mercy on whom I'll show
Mercy.
And I will execute judgment on whom I will execute judgment and he
chooses to have mercy on Israel.
And the reason you know, the reason why he chooses have
mercy is because and Moses reminds him of this.
As does I mean Abraham reminds him of his Covenant
Moses reminds him of his Covenant. They remind him of the promises
that he's made not that he didn't know him already.
But through the prayers of these leaders.
God remembers his promises to his people and
The most important promise he remembers is the promise of
the seed.
If he destroys Israel on the spot what happens to
the line of the seed?
It's gone.
God remembers his promise so
at that point after Exodus 34
at that point from Exodus 34:35ish.
Through the Book of Leviticus, which is everybody's favorite
book of the Bible through Deuteronomy.
Or through numbers, excuse me through numbers 10 so last few
chapters of Exodus all of Leviticus.
First portion of the Book of Numbers Israel is
sitting at the foot of the mountain and God is just giving them law
after law after law after law after
law.
And finally in numbers 10, he says, all right. We're ready to go
now.
We're gonna go from Mount Sinai.
to the promised land
they get to their they get ready to go into the Promised Land.
The Israelites say wait a minute. We don't want to
go in yet.
We want to check it out first.
remember
They just saw God.
Do what?
kill all them people back there
bring them through the water.
Set them up with food and water in the wilderness.
Park them at the base of a mountain Thunder's rolling
lightning flashing.
Hang on God. We don't know if we really trust you.
to go into this place
So these are I'd say wait before we go in listen 12 Spies.
Charles spice come back only two Joshua and Caleb report.
Yeah, we can go in God's got us.
We're good the other 10 are like no we're afraid.
And this is the irony of that and this is
going to be an irony throughout the historical books the irony of
that.
the irony of Israel doubting
right in front of the Red Sea the irony of the spies doubting
right here the irony of the people in Joshua
and especially in judges fearing and doubting.
The irony of that is that when God gives Israel
the law and especially the laws that have to
do with the conquest going into the land and conquering it. The irony.
Is that what God says is
I'm going before you and these nations will fear and
tremble at my sight.
and instead
At the banks of the Red Sea at the base of
Mount Sinai and at the edge of the promised land.
It is Israel God's people who respond
with fear and anxiety and doubt.
And God says at that point when the ten
spies come back.
I'm out.
I'm done with this generation.
That generation wanders in the wilderness for 40 years. There's all kinds of
stuff that happens like the fiery serpent, which is important, but we don't
have to talk about it. They wander in the wilderness.
For 40 years, they eventually die off and then
what does God do once again?
more law
Deuteronomy
Same law that he already gave.
But this time it's to the second generation the generation that didn't witness The
Exodus.
that didn't
you know, they weren't adults essentially at Sinai.
And so it gives them the law again.
and it's very clear in the law in Deuteronomy that
Israel is called to the same thing.
That Adam and Eve were called to do and that Abraham was
called to do and that God promised to do through the Seed of Abraham.
They were supposed to go and be fruitful multiply rule over
God's place the Promised Land.
They were supposed to go in and care for the place.
And ultimately they were going to do all of that through obedience to
God's word that he gave them.
But they go into the land.
And if you read Joshua and judges back to back
what you'll find is that Joshua has some positive
things to say, but there's hints of failure
along the way so that by the end of the book you see that
this was actually a failure.
We read the book of Joshua and it sort of triumphant in the beginning and yeah,
we're gonna go get it. But by the end of the book If you read through the
whole book,
What you find is that over and over again the author
says and the Philistines were still in the
land and the Philistines were still in the land and the
Philistines were still in the land and the Philistines were still
in the land.
Israel was supposed to go in and as a
means of God's judgment against those Nations put the
ban on them destroy them.
And instead Israel goes in and this is in the Book of Joshua,
but we see it especially in judges in the Book of Joshua and
judges they go in and they don't do what God Said.
They don't keep themselves from idols.
They don't follow his rules.
About the forbidden fruit in this case. It's not fruit. It's people.
They're not by the way really fast. I got to make
this really fast.
Joshua and judges do not teach
a kind of
Ethnic superiority of anybody.
Okay, the reason that God sends Israel into destroy
the Canaanites is not because of some
kind of ethnic or racist issue
The reason that God sends Israel to destroy the Canaanites has
nothing to do it that's necessity or race at all. It has to do with the sinfulness of
the people in the land and God uses Israel as an
instrument for judgment. He does the same thing later on with
Babylon and with Assyria as an instrument of judgment against Israel.
In Joshua and judges in the whole Old
Testament salvation is never an issue of net
ethnicity or race.
Judgment is never an issue of ethnicity or
race in those books. The issue is whether or not you place
your faith in the one true God of the universe Yahweh.
That's it.
And if you do you're saved if you don't you're judged.
And what we see in Joshua is Israel is being judged.
For failing to follow God's law and for failing to exercise
faith in Yahweh. So you think you know for some
of you who know, Joshua will the story of Aiken?
Aiken was supposed to put the ban.
On the city of AI you're supposed to help destroy it.
Everybody was supposed to help destroy it they were supposed to.
Destroy everything and Aiken keeps a little
bit to himself he touches what's forbidden just like Eve did.
And what God does is he puts the Judgment that
was reserved for AI onto Aiken in his
clan.
God is Not partial with respect to ethnicity
or race.
His judgment is for all those who reject him
his salvation is for all those who trust in
him.
So we get through Joshua and it's like super cool at
the beginning and then by the end, we're like, oh wait, maybe you guys didn't do such
a good job and then judges pulls the curtain back and says,
yeah everybody really really was terrible the entire
time.
You know, I don't want to like fly by the
seat, you know the seat here and trample on
everybody's favorite bible stories, but like Gideon.
Dude, Gideon is actually an example. Yes in some
ways of Faith but in a lot of ways of doubt.
God tells him very clearly what to do
and he's like wait a minute. Hang on God.
Let me just check that real fast.
Can we do a quality check here? Make sure I heard you right.
He doesn't over and over and by the end of the story of
Gideon Gideon is actually.
Associated with idle worship like Gideon is
not a guy who is faithful all
the way through but neither was Abraham.
Neither was Noah neither was Moses. I mean all of these men and
women in the Old Testament that are portrayed here.
What we need to see is that yes, there are signs that
God is moving Among Us people there are signs of faithfulness among
them. But ultimately everybody's failing left and right.
And remember what we're what we're wanting to see out
of that is that none of them?
None of them are who who are waiting on?
the seed
none of them are the seed.
They kind of look like the seed.
Not the seed.
We got through Genesis and we said well Joshua was the
looks the most like it, but he wasn't in the land. He didn't crush
the head of the serpent.
He died.
We get to Moses.
Moses isn't from the tribe of Judah first of all, so that's like
you're out already, but then he like kills a
guy with a trident and all kinds of stuff and you're out.
You look like it, but you're not it.
In Deuteronomy before I get too
far along and Deuteronomy Moses adds an expectation.
In Deuteronomy 18 and then Deuteronomy 34 Moses adds
the expectation that there will be a prophet greater than Moses that
comes.
So now we're looking for the seed of Adam
seed of Eve.
Line of Abraham Prophet greater than Moses. And
here's where Joshua and judges come in. Joshua looks
like it for a while.
And then you get to Ai, and it's like, whoops.
not Joshua
You get to the end of the Book of Joshua the Philistines the Philistines the Philistines the
Philistines not Joshua.
You get to judges and it's like any you people.
You all read the Book of Judges lately like it is crazy and
then
we get to and I mean things are so bad.
by the end of judges
that here's what happens at the end
of the Book of Judges.
One Tribe of Israel
The Tribe of Benjamin has committed an atrocity so
great.
And I don't I'm not going to go into the details because it would I just
don't want to bring it up at the moment without having the time
to spend on it.
The Tribe of Benjamin commits an atrocity so great. It's
worse than Sodom and Gomorrah like the author portrays this
event like Sodom and Gomorrah, but worse
here is a tribe of Israel that is worse than
the worst cities.
in Genesis
and God calls Judah.
to lead Israel and putting the ban on Benjamin
Israel has been told go into the land and destroy all
of the Nations there.
Don't make a pact with them don't leave any
of them alive. Don't take their stuff go in and
destroy it.
And they fail and they fail so miserably.
That at the end of Judges we see and really actually
the story takes place at the beginning of the conquest. So
the author of Judges goes back all the way to the beginning and says, hey
this was always the case.
At the end of the book he tells this story where Benjamin has
done something so bad that it's worse than the Nations. They're
supposed to be destroying and God says, you know what you're
gonna get destroyed.
You deserve judgment.
But what did Judah did you know how this ends?
Judah and the other tribes of Israel like the end of the book is they're
all just like
we're tired of fighting.
Let's just kind of stand here and look at each other. I mean seriously, that's
literally the end of the book.
So nobody's obeyed God nobody.
The Nations around them aren't obeying God. The Israelites aren't
obeying. God. Nobody's obeying God.
And in the book like man, where is the Hope here?
Like we've gone through.
and we punctuated this a number of times right you
get to Genesis 11 and you're like well
Where's the Hope Abraham?
promises Dave Ram
you get to Exodus 34 and the golden calf and you go.
Where's the hope?
God remembers his promises you get to the end
of judges and you're like man this this has got to be it like these people are terrible. I
agree with you god. Everybody needs to be destroyed.
And then we jump into first Samuel in the first story is the
story of of Hannah and her prayer and there's there's
these punctuations of faithfulness where God is working through
particular people. They're not the seed but God's working
through people. He's working through Moses. He's working through Joshua. We see
Caleb being a faithful man in the Book of Joshua and
judges.
And we get to First Samuel and Hannah is a
faithful woman.
I mean, there's so much going on guys. She's a barren woman.
She goes in praising the temple God opens. Her womb gives
her a son he serves in the temple and then he
becomes the man who anoints the king.
Now you just think about that for a second you think about the Gospel of Luke how it
starts Elizabeth is a barren woman who goes
and prays the temple God opens her womb she gives
birth to a son who's dedicated to the Lord and He anoints the
coming King Jesus.
That's the kind of thing that the Bible does but
first Samuel there's the hope.
In the midst of this darkness, that is the end of the Book of
Judges.
Where Israel looks worse than Sodom and
Gomorrah.
God brings hope
and he brings hope through this man Samuel Israel. Meanwhile is
still terrible. The priests are offering meat
sacrifice Idols the high priest Sons.
They're bringing women in to have relations with him in
the Tabernacle like it's terrible.
In the midst of all that Israel says we want to
King like the Nations.
To fight our battles for us.
And God says okay. Here's here's Saul.
They want to look like the Nations, right? And again this goes back
to this comment about
if Israel had obeyed if they had had faith.
God was going before them and the nations would
bow in fear and trembling.
And instead here's Israel fearing and trembling
everyone around them. So we need to strong man.
We need a big tall strong guy.
Who's going to go out and fight our battles for us?
We don't need you God.
We need big strong, man.
So he gives him Saul Saul's terrible.
God says I've had enough of that David Okay, so
What happens at this point is?
The story of David and Solomon is going to mirror everything. We've said
both of them look like
the seed
the seed has gone from Eve to
Noah and then to
shim and then eventually
to Abraham Isaac Jacob
Judah.
And then we've been going through the conquest and finally we get to King David
and it's through the line of David that the seed is going
to come. So we keep we keep kind of narrowing down.
Where the seed is coming from?
And this is this is pretty much the narrowest point. It's going
to be not just a human being.
seed of woman
it's not even just gonna be an Israelite see Dev Abraham.
It's not even just gonna be a judai.
It's gonna be specifically from the line of David from the
line of Kings.
and in a number of ways
Both David and Solomon look like
they're them. They're the seed.
because if you read the stories of David and Solomon at the beginning
What do they do?
They conquer people around them that were left unconquered.
They expand the borders of the land.
David asks God to build a temple
and then Solomon builds the temple this permanent dwelling place
that people will have with God.
It says they're fruitful multiply David actually says that
Israel is bone of his bone and flesh of his flesh.
in second Samuel 5
like this is a direct comment.
On we're getting back to the Garden y'all.
We're fine. It's finally happening.
I remember the it's happening. That's what's
going on here.
David and Solomon both in many ways look like they're the
one
and if you if you think about those four tasks and the
four promises to Abraham.
each both David and Solomon map on to those
they're kings. They're ruling.
They're being fruitful and multiplying and expanding the
borders of the land.
The land is Flowing with milk and honey. They're caring
for it.
What's that fourth one?
Do they obey?
Even even with Solomon right you add at will come
back to that one. Even with Solomon Solomon asked for wisdom.
Like Joseph remember that?
Solomon builds this Temple this place for God to dwell with his
people.
They look like
new atoms
And yet both of them failed The crucial point that everybody else
has failed at so far.
Which is they can't obey?
David takes another man's wife.
As his own Bathsheba and then has that man
killed on the front lines of battle.
And so again, I mean you hear that, right?
David takes he touches something that
is forbidden.
Just like Eve did just like Aiken did.
He fails.
Solomon
same thing.
We read all in this I can't like.
I would I would have Bible study with you y'all until
The cows come home like we I could just
talk about this stuff all the time. But if you read this the descriptions of
the temple, which everybody skips over because it
is super boring.
If you can't hear the resonances.
but here's a tip all those things that
first first Kings describes when Solomon
is building the Temple
basins of water and animals holding it
and vines on the walls and gold and Lilies
all of that is a reference to
say something wrong.
All that's a reference to the garden.
The temple looks like a garden.
So this Temple is being described in such a way that
it's obviously the place that's supposed to be where God
draws those people just like God calling Israel up on the Mount Sinai just
like him giving them the Tabernacle laws. Here's this
Temple. That's that looks like the garden.
And God says I'm going to dwell with my people in
my place.
And yet David and Solomon both
failed just like Adam failed and Noah failed and
Abraham failed and Isaac failed and Jacob failed and Judah failed.
and Moses failed and Israel failed
David and Solomon both failed
And if Solomon is is the high point of Israel's history,
it's also the beginning of its failure. It's
it's really
I would say it's final destruction.
Like you get to Solomon, it's this it's this High Point.
And then after Solomon it goes downhill so fast just like
Adam and Eve right after they sin Cain
and Abel lamech.
demon sex and Genesis 6 Tower of
Babel like it all goes
crazy really fast Solomon dies
Israel splits into two North
and South
Judah is the southern Kingdom Israel is the
northern kingdom. Sometimes that's described as Judah
and Benjamin are the two names that are used because
Benjamin migrates North eventually.
Remember Judah and Benjamin remember how
Judah was supposed to destroy Benjamin.
remember that
Southern Northern
the kings of those two now distinct Nations
Are almost all terrible?
The if you read through the second half
of First Kings and all of Second Kings, what you're
going to hear is just like story after story after
Story. Excuse me, where it just gets worse and worse
and you can't even tell the difference between these guys anymore.
Like wait, which horrible King was that?
It sounds like that horrible King. They're all terrible.
And eventually you get to the Exile that happens
throughout Second Kings. First of all, the Northern
Kingdom of Israel is destroyed by the Assyrians in
721 BC. And then the southern
Kingdom of Judah is destroyed by the Babylonians in
586 BC and Israel
is cast out of the land.
And this is what God told Israel. He would do in
Deuteronomy. He says if you fail to keep my law the land
will vomit you out.
Remember they were supposed to care for the land.
Well, they have destroyed the land and the land has vomited
them out.
Just like God kicked Adam and
Eve out of the garden.
Israel's story is Adam's story?
Adam and Eve were given instructions to be fruitful and
multiply care for God's place rule over God's place
and Obey God's word.
And they failed and God kicked them out.
Israel was told to be fruitful multiply care for God's
place rule over God's place and obey his word
and they didn't obey and got kicked him out.
Adam's story is Israel's story and Adams and
Israel. Story is our story.
Adam couldn't obey.
Noah couldn't obey Abraham Isaac Jacob Judah
Moses
David Solomon me and you
none of us can't obey.
None of us are able on our own.
To bring ourselves into relationship with God
or maintain a relationship with God.
This is why Paul says in Galatians that the law was given
as a teacher.
a Schoolmaster
the law
wasn't intended to describe Utopia.
A perfect place. I mean in a perfect place nobody's murdering each
other and you don't have to deal with that in a court of law.
nobody's holding slaves in a Utopia
God gave God gave Israel the law to teach
them that they could not stay away
from sin and Death on their own.
But Paul also says in Galatians that he gave the law.
as a guardrail, basically
To guard what what are we
waiting on? Who are we waiting on the whole time?
The seed if Israel is obliterated. What
else is obliterated?
the line of the seed
so God gives them the law to teach
them about their need for him.
And also to make sure that they don't get so bad.
That he obliterates them and the line of
the seed is destroyed.
So we get to the end of Second Kings.
Everybody has been kicked out of the land.
There are some stories that there's still hope in
Esther and Ezra Nehemiah.
We don't have time.
It's my fault. I know it's my fault. I
have only myself to blame but like Ezra
man, he's crossing a river. He's crossing the
Jordan River. He brings the temple vessels. It's a new
Exodus anyway.
The final section of the Old Testament is the
wisdom literature and then the prophets.
In different ways both the wisdom literature Psalms Proverbs
Ecclesiastes Etc. And the prophets Isaiah Jeremiah
Ezekiel, Daniel.
Etc all of those are pointing forward
to the hope that Israel still has
okay. So what I want what I want
you to do is think about again where we
started with Psalm 78.
Think about where was Psalm 78?
and that's the story we've just been telling
Right Israel, can't obey.
Israel needs
what do they need? What do they need to obey?
What this is what Moses
says in numbers?
Which I you know, I get it nobody reads numbers. But if you read numbers, we we see
in numbers is numbers 14 when Joshua
and Caleb come back and give a good report. It says that
because it was because Caleb had a different spirit
in him.
What what do they need? And what does Adam need? What is
Abraham need? What is
Isaac and Jacob Etc what they need to
obey
a different spirit
What do we need to obey?
so Psalm 78 what I read at. The beginning was
the story that we've just walked through.
At the end of the story of Israel, they are waiting.
for something
they're waiting for the seed.
But they're also waiting for the seed to come in
a way that they recognize in a
way that they expect in a way that restores what
now now not just what Adam lost but what Israel lost
think about what Israel's lost.
Think about what Adams lost Adam lost his ability
to rule over God's Place. Israel has lost their King.
from the line of David
Adam lost
the garden that he was to cultivate and keep
Israel has been kicked out of the land flowing with milk and honey.
Adam
lost
and really sin affected Adam's ability to be fruitful
and multiply Israel is now scattered not
a nation.
Not making more image bears not expanding
the borders.
Adam couldn't obey Israel can obey
and just like Adam was waiting on the seed.
Israel's waiting on the seed
so in the wisdom literature and the prophets
what we find is that Israel's story isn't over.
Just like we talked about in Genesis and this is why I spent so much
time on Genesis and the first half of Exodus.
Because if you can get the sense of Israel's story from the
beginning.
You can understand how it ends.
And this is why I can go a lot faster this week because if you
have that basic understanding of how it started.
You can understand where it's going and how it is.
Okay, so Israel's waiting now in the wisdom literature
and the prophets.
Were they waiting on?
well
Let's talk through it. Let's talk through the things we've just
mentioned.
Israel is
Trying to decide where to start. He just want to start with is
visuals waiting for the seed seed of woman. Okay, so that's a
very clear expectation in the profits and in the wisdom literature. See
the one where is he?
He's going to be the one to restore.
Israel and Adam were kicked out of the land.
They're waiting for the land to be restored for them to be there the
way that the New Testament puts it
is they're waiting to be restored from exile.
They've been kicked out. They've been exiled they're waiting to come back in.
To the land where they're going to care for it. They're going to cultivate it.
and you think about that think about
how about for just a second what God did when he
kicked Adam and Eve out of the garden.
He put these two angels on the side and he also clothed them with skins,
right?
And then we saw an exodus. How is he going to release his people from bondage?
through sacrifice
right, so a kind of
Natural way to connect the dots here is that they're waiting
to be brought back into the land, but they know they need forgiveness of
sin.
to do that
and especially through
blood
also related to God's place. They're waiting
for the temple to be restored.
There's a lot of prophecies about the temple being rebuilt.
In the profits, there's a lot of talk about the temple in the
wisdom literature. They're waiting for God's place to be restored because
the temple as a building
the building itself is a
sign of what really matters which
is
the presence of God
they're waiting on God's presence to be in their midst again.
They're waiting on.
God to restore them ruling over God's Place specifically with
a king from the line of David.
So just so I remember what I've already said seed.
land sacrifice Temple King
remember in Exodus that one of
the ways that he brings his people out of bondage and into the
land is through victory over his enemy. So there's a lot of promises about God
having victory.
over his enemies
And ultimately that Victory is a victory over the final enemy
and this is true in the Old Testament as well as the New Testament
the final enemy is death.
So there is an expectation of Resurrection not just death and suffering
but Resurrection.
there is
an expectation that Israel will no longer be two Nations,
but one Israel and Judah will be reunited.
and there's an expectation that
the Holy Spirit
will dwell in the hearts of God's people.
Because they know we can't obey you on our
own God.
We need your Holy Spirit. This is the promise of the New Covenant.
Jeremiah 31 Ezekiel 36
the New Covenant promise is that God's spirit will dwell
with his people not just in their midst.
in the Tabernacle and Temple but in their hearts
and it expressly says so that you can obey.
all of this
all of this and this this is kind of like the summary expectation
the tenth one here. All of
this is going to happen when God sins
his Messiah.
His Messiah is the seed his Messiah is the
king from the line of David his Messiah is
the one who's going to suffer and Rise Again.
rebuild the Temple
bring the people back in the land reunite them as one people.
The Messiah is the one who's going to do that the anointed one.
Okay, so
this is where the Old Testament ends.
the Old Testament ends in expectation
The Old Testament is not a finished book. So
to speak we got to get to part two.
the Old Testament authors all realize that
I mean every single book you name me an Old
Testament book. I'll tell you how it's waiting on something.
waiting
on those 10 things basically
We're waiting at the end of the Old Testament for the arrival
of this Messiah.
Okay, so I want you to
I want you to just take a deep breath.
Because I need to take a deep breath.
We just went from Exodus 15 to Malachi 4.
So let's all take a deep breath.
and
what you need to
sort of let sink in.
is
How those things are connected, right? So when we
talk about the New Testament and we talk about Jesus we often talk about
how Jesus fulfills over 400 prophecies found the Old
Testament, right? That's true.
but
he's fulfilling those.
As a fulfillment not just of as a kind of like math calculation.
Like oh it says I'll be born in Bethlehem. So I'm born in Bethlehem.
But those promises those prophecies in the
Old Testament are actually related to that whole story that
we've just told.
Jesus is fulfilling the Prophecies of
the Old Testament because
he is.
Fulfilling the promises that God made to Abraham to restore
what Adam lost.
Jesus is fulfilling those Prophecies of the
Old Testament because
He's bringing a new Exodus where he's going to bring his people out
of bondage.
Not just to Egypt who cares about Egypt.
but to sin
our our first and last enemy.
Jesus is fulfilling these promises.
Because he's finally going to bring his people into God's place.
Where they'll dwell with him forever.
That's what Jesus is doing and not you know, this is why in
the first week we started with how far are
the effects of sin?
Well the effects of sin stretch to our relationship with God
and also to our relationship with each other and also to the
relationship with the creation itself.
And so what does God promise you he's going to do he promises Abraham. He's going
to reverse the curse. He's going to restore everything that Abraham wants
or that Adam lost.
How is he going to do it through a new Exodus. Who is that going
to be the Messiah who's gonna bring
those other nine things and what the New Testament does is identifies
that person as Jesus.
Okay, so I want us to keep walking.
For the time remaining through the New Testament and all
I'm really going to do is use those
categories and give you little Clues as to how to see in
the New Testament these things.
But in the New Testament what we find
is that it is Jesus who comes as the seed of woman.
and so
think about the genealogy in the Gospel of Luke.
We read the one in Matthew a lot. But do you know where the
one in Luke stretches all the way back to?
Adam
that's a very direct reference to we're waiting on.
the seed of woman
Jesus the seat of woman Jesus is the son of David. I mean
if you just read the gospels over and over again, the gospel
is clearly identified Jesus as the son of David. That's
the kind of easy one, right? These are kind of easy.
They'll get harder as we go off.
They identified Jesus as the seed of woman as the son of David.
They identified Jesus as the suffering servant in the book of Isaiah. Especially
we have this promise of the suffering servant who is
going to suffer and die on behalf of Israel
and the Nations really it's
through Israel to the nations are saved.
It's the suffering servant. He's
going to pay the penalty for their sins.
And it's through that suffering that God is going to
forgive them.
The New Testament the gospels clearly identified Jesus as
the suffering servant.
The New Testament clearly identifies Jesus as the
one who brings the resurrection of the Dead.
I mean, I don't I don't really think I have to blame her that but Jesus
roasting the dead everybody and that was a fulfillment of the promise to
the Israelites that was related to
and specifically given to show God's victory
over enemies and even over
the power of sin and death.
Right. Here's the power that from the beginning has been harassing
Humanity sin and death.
Resurrection Jesus wins over sin
and death
and he wins that victory for Israel and through Israel for
the Nations.
Jesus restores the nation of Israel
how many disciples does Jesus call?
how many sons of Jacob were there?
12 how many tribes of Israel were there?
I mean
There's not a verse that says the 12 disciples are representations
of the Twelve Tribes of Israel. But I mean like if you want
to think that's coincidence, I guess you can that's fine, but it's not
coincidence.
In fact, if you read the calling of the disciples and the
stories around that it is obvious that Jesus is reorganizing the
nation of Israel around himself.
Jesus restores Israel
Jesus gives the Holy Spirit
he obeys and we'll talk about that in a second and then gives
the holy spirit. So there's people can obey.
Jesus also, like I just said obeys where
we can't.
Israel goes out into the Wilderness. And what's the first thing they
do?
They sin they doubt they lack Faith. Jesus
goes in the wilderness. And what does he do?
He obeys.
I mean
if you think about if you think about the gospel of Matthew
in particular just second.
At the beginning of Matthew we have a genealogy genealogies
are important.
Jesus is from the line of David.
and the line of Abraham
the beginning and end of Israel's story. I
know there's more people after David but these are the two dominant
figures of Israel's history.
Jesus is from the line of
David and Abraham
But he's not just from the line of David and Abraham. He's
ultimately from God himself because he is God himself in the
flesh.
Immediately what happens to Jesus once he's born?
What's the next story in Matthew 2?
Do you know?
Y'all can talk louder than that. Jesus won't zap
you if you're wrong. The answer is.
Herod tries to kill all the male children
when did that happen?
in Exodus with Moses
Herod tries to kill all the male children. Where does Joseph go
with his family?
Egypt
then they come back from Egypt. And what's the
next story Matthew 3?
Baptism where is Jesus baptized?
In the Jordan where did Israel cross from The
Exodus into the promised land across the Jordan?
He goes across the Jordan Air into the Jordan now that Jordan he's in
the wilderness.
just like
God brought Israel across the Red Sea Into the
Wilderness
What does Israel do in the wilderness?
They sin. What does Jesus do in the
wilderness?
He succeeds he obeys.
Israel then after they fail in the
wilderness in Exodus 16 and 17. They go to Mount Sinai and
God gives them a law.
What does Jesus do after he succeeds in the wilderness in Matthew
5?
He stands on a mountain and delivers the law The Sermon
on the Mount.
Jesus is greater than Moses.
Wait a minute Deuteronomy 18 during Army 34 worrying on a
prophet greater than Moses. Here. He is.
Matthew 8 and 9
wind waves obey him Authority interpretation of
Israel scriptures
Finally we get to Matthew 17. Jesus goes up on
the mountain with Peter James and John and what happens the glory of
God shines from Jesus himself, and
they see it. Whereas Moses goes up
on a mountain and the glory of God is on Moses's face.
Jesus goes up on the mountain and the glory of
God comes from within him. He's not just a man.
He's not just a human being
he is God in the flesh.
You go through the rest of the teaching material. Jesus gets to Jerusalem.
Goes in the temple. He pronounces judgment over
it destruction of it.
Why I mean, he says this in Matthew says it in Mark. He says
it most clearly in John in John 2. Why does
Jesus pronounce judgment on the temple? And it's destruction and then
say in John 2 in three days. I'll rise it
up.
Because the dwelling of God with human beings is
no longer in a building. It's in a person and it's
the person of Jesus Christ.
So there's the temple one by the way if you're keeping track of
the 10 things.
Jesus says he himself is the temple.
You get to the end of Matthew?
What happens at the crucifixion?
And about the ninth hour what?
Darkness fell over the land Darkness
death of the firstborn son
Temple curtains torn into
and then Jesus rises from the dead and once
again stands on a mountain.
at the edge
of his people's Mission and says all authority on
in heaven and on Earth has been given to me go there
for an all nations.
just like Moses stood at the edge of the land and said
go into the land. Jesus is greater than
Moses. Right? This is the way this is the way that the New Testament
tells you who Jesus is.
He's he's greater than everybody
else in Israel's history because he is
the god of Israel in the flesh.
Through the Incarnation of God the son.
That's how the New Testament tells you who Jesus is. He's
what Israel has been waiting for because he is God himself
come down to Israel.
Israel couldn't do it. We can't do it. We need God
to do it for us. And God. Does that through his son
Jesus? I mean that's like the whole
Bible is the promise and fulfillment of
the gospel and the gospel. Is this you and I were
made to dwell with God.
And we mess it up every time.
We can't make our way back to God our sins separates
us from God and so because God is
gracious and kind he comes down to us and the person of his son.
In Jesus of Nazareth and obeys on our behalf. He lives
the life that we can't.
He lives the life that Adam couldn't he lives the life that
Abraham couldn't that all of Israel couldn't live and that
we can't live.
He lives the life that we can't on our behalf. And then
he dies the death that we deserve.
On our behalf. He is the suffering servant who takes the place of
his people.
He goes down into enemy territory.
the place of the dead and declares his victory
over death and then he rises from the dead and victory and
says
All authority what all authority is mine? Why
because I have defeated literally every enemy in
my obedient life my vicarious
death and now by Victorious resurrection, and
so now I Rise into heaven I Ascend into heaven to
rule at the right hand of God the Father.
He's ruling over not just over a piece of land.
He is ruling over all things.
This is the Fulfillment of the promises of Abraham two
Abraham. This is the Fulfillment of the hope that we have that the
seed is going to come in Reverse The Curse.
Adam Israel
We're supposed to be fruitful multiply. What
does Jesus doing right now? He's sending his people out into the
Nations to share the gospel.
In the book of Acts. I know I'm running a time in the book of Acts.
Every time the gospel goes to a new place acts 6.
acts 12 and Acts 19
every time the gospel goes to a new place. So first of all to the
Samaritans or
the judeans and the Samaritans and then
to the Gentiles every time the gospel goes to a new place.
the book of act says and the word of God
was fruitful and multiplied
Jesus is being fruitful and multiplying.
Through the proclamation of the Gospel by his people.
and by the power of His spirit
Jesus is being fruitful and multiplying right now.
By the power of spirit and through the proclamation of the Gospel by his people
to the world.
Jesus is ruling over not just
the garden
not just the promised land. Jesus is ruling
over.
everything
right now
Jesus has cared for God's place.
in John in John chapter 20
John 19 and 20 Jesus rises from the dead and he rises
in a garden.
With a woman Mary and the woman says what does
Mary say? She thought he was the gardener, right? This is
an obvious Garden scene.
Jesus and his resurrection from the dead is restoring creation
itself.
That's what's happening. Jesus cares for
God's world.
And obviously he obeys where
we can't and now gives us a spirit so that we can obey.
Why are we still here then?
If Jesus has fulfilled all the promises.
To Abraham if he's restored what Adam lost? Why are
we still here?
Why y'all think?
What are we doing?
What are we what was the book of act say being fruitful and multiplying
because God promises in the Old Testament. He's going to bring the Gentiles
in.
God is God is being fruitful and multiplying
filling the Earth with every tribe tongue and Nation.
full of image bearers
and those restored
to their full Humanity by the grace of the Lord
Jesus
That's why we're still here. We're still here from Mission.
That's it.
Jesus second Corinthians, 1:20 says
all the promises of God find their yes in Christ Jesus.
That's not the promise that he you know.
Made to me and my dorm room when I asked a red
helicopter to fly over this guy. That is the promise that he makes
to his people in the Old Testament all the promises of God
find their yes in Christ. Jesus. Jesus is fulfilled
what Israel is waiting on what we are still here for
is to share the good news with those
around us.
and so finally when Jesus returns
in Revelation 21 and 22
This is what we find.
We find Heaven coming down to earth.
God once again comes down.
To us this time forever.
He comes down in the New Jerusalem, which is described like a temple.
Because that's where God dwells with this people.
Jesus is on his throne in the middle of his people
in Revelation 21 six and
seven.
Five six and seven really declaring that he's
secured this place by his blood.
And that we live with him forever. This is the this is God's people
dwelling in God's Place finally and forever in Revelation 21 and
22 when Jesus returns.
Jesus is on the throne ruling. Jesus has been fruitful and
multiply if you if you read the description of
the people in Revelation 21 and 22 and throughout the
Book of Revelation.
They're everywhere.
The Earth has been filled.
This place is a place that has trees everywhere and
water flowing and the leaves are for the healing of the
Nations. This is a place that God has restored through his
son Jesus and that is a place that can
be cared and cultivated but also cares for
us.
And ultimately it's a place where there will be no more sin.
Because God in Christ is obeyed on our
behalf and has given us his spirit so that we can obey and when
we too are raised with Christ, we will no longer have sinful fleshly
bodies, but raised new bodies.
made clean by the blood of Jesus
Where are we? I mean this is this is where we need to
ask. Okay, if you can get a whole sense of the Bible here are
two things that
I think will help.
In your life number one when you get a whole sense of the
Bible. It's easier to read books of the Bible you tend to avoid?
Okay, so what's the what you know if you want to ask what's the application?
What's the cash value here? Where how does my story intersect with
this story number one, this is gonna I hope help you
in your Bible reading.
If you can if you can say, okay.
I'm not really sure what to do with Obadiah.
But I know that in the context of this whole story
all of these Prophets.
Are talking about the judgment and salvation of
Israel and Nations and waiting on the Messiah to come. Okay, that
helps me.
Obadiah is always singled out. I feel really bad for Obadiah. It's
like would you rather be in a desert island with John or obadia?
It's like man. Come on.
Opa dies inspired by the holy spirit, so
You know, I think in that sense.
I hope that this will help you with your Bible reading but
the second thing is this.
in terms of
the question
Why are we still here or why am I here?
What's my purpose?
What what am I doing? What is my life for?
It doesn't matter who you are. Your life
is intended to be.
A reflection of the god of the universe because
you are his image bear.
And if you don't know Jesus.
then what you need to hear from this, is that the only way
That you can actually fulfill your purpose in life
is to submit your life to Christ come to him for forgiveness and
repentance and Faith believe that God raises him
from the dead.
And Trust In His Holy Spirit to transform your life.
That's I mean, that's the reason we're all here.
We're not here for fame or fortune or Glory or money
or sex or whatever.
Or even or even like less.
Sinful Idols, they're all sinful by the way, but like,
you know, we're not here just for our family.
Or to love our family. We're not here to help just to help people. We're
here to ultimately Worship the Lord Jesus.
the second person of the triang god
and tell other people about it.
That's why we're here and you do that through your jobs and through your family
your relationships. But those things are secondary to the primary
purpose of your existence. And if you don't know Jesus in
this room,
this whole story is an invitation for you to come to
him.
If you want to talk about that come talk to me come talk to Phil anybody.
But if you're a Christian in this room, which I assume many of you most of you
are maybe all of you maybe 100% if you're a Christian this
room, it's really easy to like go through the day-to-day
the grind even, you know, if you're not at work
anymore you're retired or whatever maybe difficult to think.
And what am I I can't watch another episode of
Everybody Loves Raymond. Like what? Why am I here?
It's the same thing is true.
You are here.
to Worship the Lord Jesus
second person to try and God In the Flesh
you are here to live by his Spirit walk by his
spirit and to be a testimony to who he is.
You are here to be on Mission.
You are here to share the gospel.
And that doesn't you know, that is more that's broader
than I want you to go knock on doors on Saturday. I
would do want you to knock on doors on Saturday, but it includes living
your daily life in a way that glorifies God.
as a testimony to him
That's why we're here.
We're still here because God is still saving people.
And he wants us.
To be the ones who to proclaim the gospel to the
people around us to the Nations around us who don't know him.
So when you I mean maybe some of you don't feel this but there
are lots of people these days who feel a lack of purpose a
lack of energy a lack of drive if that's you
you're not going to find it in, you know.
Joining CrossFit or you know
getting a promotion or having grandkids.
or whatever all those things fade
What doesn't fade is the god of the universe who
made you in His image?
Who saved you by the blood of his son and who wants
you to testify to him by the power of His spirit?
Let's pray God. Thank you for your word.
Thank you that you have inspired it by the
power of your holy spirit. Thank you that this one story is
ultimately the story of your son.
That while we were yet sinners while all
of us.
from Adam to today
couldn't obey you sent your son to live the life that
we can't.
To Die the death that we deserve for
our sin to rise Victorious over sin and
death.
to ascend into heaven and Rule and Reign Over All
Things
to build your church and your kingdom through the proclamation of
the Gospel as the word is fruitful and multiplies through
evangelism and ultimately to come back in glory.
right raising the living in the Dead
judging them
and dwelling together forever with your people.
Help us to understand our story in light of your story help us
to understand our purpose in light of your purpose for creation.
and Redemption
help us to just love our Bibles God.
not because
not because our bibles are where we find life. But because our
bibles are the way that you communicate to us. And
you're the one in whom we have life.
We pray that you make us more like your son Jesus and you
do it by the power of your Holy Spirit. We ask in Christ name.
amen
Let's give him a big hand.
Wanted to remind you the next week. We start our four
week series on our role in a culture War
next week. We will be addressing the lgbtq. Agenda.
We have Stephen black from first own Ministries
going to come as our guest and he is in
his ministry in first stone responds to
and helps people who are still caught in
sexual Brokenness. And so it's going to be really
really helpful. I don't know if you knew this but the world seems to
be kind of stuck on that issue and we as Christian
people because we are called to be fruitful and multiply
and we are here to be countercultural and
change the culture as the holy spirit
gives us understanding how to do so that we need to address these
issues. So we will look at that issue the following
issue. We'll have a panel discussing race relations and
Reconciliation after that. We'll be looking at American freedom.
I want to tell you this I told
this group right here. I was studying because I was going
to be the one to
About religious liberty and I was set in this book.
It was a really good book and I thought man. I wish
that this guy the guy that wrote this book could come so
I emailed him and he's gonna be
here so he'll be here on Zoom, but Dr.
Bruce Ashford theology Professor.
It's a Southeastern Seminary
a Baptist Theological Seminary is
going to be here by via Zoom so gonna be a great month and I don't
know how we can do any better than we did with Dr.
Emerson, but thank you for coming. I think we'll have him back
if we can take the weather going as bad as it. All right.
God bless your scent.